Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricard Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Nima Bassiri. He's a
social theorist, historian, and philosopher of the human sciences
and associate professor at Duke University, where he teaches
in the programming literature. Duke's Interdisciplinary Humanities and Cultural
Studies Program, and today we're going to talk about
his book Madness and Enterprise Psychiatry, Economic Reason and
the Emergence of Pathological Value. So Dr. Basiri, welcome
to the show. It's a pleasure to everyone.
Thank you. It's a pleasure to be here.
OK, so, uh, let me ask you first, what
is the premise and the main argument of your
book before we get into details here?
Yeah, thank you for asking and thanks for having
me on the show. Um, THE, a book is
essentially uh, something of a kind of reprisal of
the history of psychiatry. And one of the things
that I've tried to do in this book is
to reimagine. The very category of madness as something
that is more than just a medical category, and
more than just a moral category, but something that's
in an economic category or an economic form, quite
literally, since its modern kind of outset. Um, AND,
um, the way I do it, and I'll just
be very brief about this, is to say that,
um, when The modern conception of madness, and here
I mean, uh, the conceptions of madness that begin
to emerge in the early 19th century, when they
arise, they introduce a certain kind of a hermeneutic
challenge to a lot of psychiatric, uh, practitioners.
OK, so what, what does hermeneutic I mean in
this particular case just for people of the audience
that might not be familiar with this kind of
terminology.
So that's great. Yeah, so an interpretive challenge. So,
um, one of the things you have to understand
in the history of psychiatry is that, um, madness
has been, um, something that people have been thinking
about for millennia. But one of the classic ways
that madness was always understood was as something akin
to what you might call a cognitive disorder. So
someone who, for instance, imagines themselves to be the
king of France, where they are in fact not.
And in this sense, madness was always, you could
say, easy to detect. You could always tell who
the person was who had some kind of a
delusional disorder. And in the beginning of the 19th
century, a new conception of madness begins to emerge
for a number of reasons that are conceptual, that
are professional, sociological. But in fact, madness is very
difficult to identify, and it became very important to
make this claim that it was very difficult to
identify. It was very latent in the population. It
was often very masked in the population, and it
would only emerge in these, um, unpredictable sorts of
ways. And so, um, uh, so this is the
kind of interpretive challenge and the, the, and I'll
say this very schematically, and we can talk about
it in more detail. But one of the, the,
the ways that psychiatry kind of inadvertently had to
come up with a kind of a framework to
make sense of how to Distinguish somebody who is
healthy from somebody who was sad was by utilizing
what you might call economic metrics or economic benchmarks.
Are they good with money? Can they work a
job? Um, CAN they accrue wealth? Um, AND this
became such an entrenched and embedded way of deciphering
the boundary between health and unhealth, that in some
ways, kind of economic appraisal. You could say got
cooked into the very concept of madness. And that's
the, that's the story I try and chart throughout
the book.
You know, I, I think that probably toward the
end of our conversation we can come back to
this point, but just to ask you a little
bit about what you just said there. I mean,
so, uh, one very interesting thing, and please correct
me if I'm if I'm wrong here in the
way I interpreted what you explored in your book,
or one very interesting idea that I got from
it is that actually, and I've had these ideas.
When reading the work of other people who approach
psychology from a more cultural perspective or look at
psychiatry within a particular social cultural context, is that,
um, I mean, the way that psychiatry developed in
the West, at least, and of course nowadays it
is, uh, I mean, for the most part, for
the most part spread across the world. World, um,
is that it developed in particular, uh, socioeconom uh
socio-cultural and economic, uh, in a particular socio-cultural and
economic context, right? I mean, uh, uh, in this
particular case, we are talking about, um, calling people
mad, uh, calling mad people who were possibly not
able to properly Uh, manage their money or work
or generate money in some way. So in that
particular case, it would be, uh, associating madness with
conduct that we expect from people in a capitalist
or an early stage capitalist society.
That's right. That's absolutely right. And in a way
it's um And, and I'll just say something briefly,
and we can certainly talk about this in a
great amount of detail, because there is some kind
of connection that I am trying to make in
the book between capitalism and irrationalism, you could say,
right, uh, by mental illness in its most kind
of paradigmatic sense. And there is a kind of
a, a, a critique, of course, of, of capital
as a, as a form of irrationality, which I
think it largely is, despite however much it masks
itself in certain forms of reasoning or economic reasoning.
And I think that some, there have been some
kind of critiques that you see from different um
positions that, um, capitalism's irrationalism will be its undoing.
And one of the things that I want to
argue in this book is I actually think capitalism
and and irrationalism go together very well, that actually,
it's not capitalism's undoing, that it, that it thrives
in some respects on certain forms of sociopolitical irrationalism.
Um, AND, and that's part of one of the
arguments I want to make in the book. And
so, of course, this relationship between health and, and
unhealth and, um, capital, it goes back very far.
Just one final point to make too, in response
to your question. There's a, a longstanding premise that
actually the thing that's most productive for capitalist enterprise
is a state of health. And this could be
the state of health of, of the, of the
population, for instance, as a kind of vital and,
and, um, Um, uh, a kind of a vital
workforce, you know, you want a healthy pop, and
this is like, this is stuff that goes back
to, to Foucault, the idea of, of course, biopolitics,
uh, a healthy population, keeping them healthy is actually
going to keep them very productive. And in this
sense, if you follow out the story, then it
would suggest somehow that forms of unhealth are actually
outside of the purview of capital. And I actually
want to convert this story and to suggest throughout
the book that actually with respect to capitalism, um,
Mental illness is actually more profound and has more
fecundity for the capitalist enterprise than than than sanity
does, for instance.
Yeah, we'll come back to that point later, but
I mean, what would you say has been the
sort of historical relationship between economic thought and psychological
science and medicine in this particular case, psychiatry as
a branch of medicine? I mean, has there been
some form of parallel between Uh, those two things
in the way that economic thought developed and, uh,
psychiatry or psychological science, clinical psychology, for example, uh,
developed as well. Yes,
there has been. And in fact, you can start
to trace, um, the relationship or the interest, um,
the kind of cross-pollinating interest between fields of economic
theory and psychological theory. Dating back to the kind
of the late 19th century, most of that story
has often been economic theorists drawing from psychological ideas
to make sense of kind of marginal utility theory
or any kind of like Um, theories where the,
the, the, the, what's at stake in the economic
thought are the activities of economic actors. And, and,
and depending on what, which sort of psychological theory
a person makes use of, um, the economic theory
will be impacted. So, for instance, John Maynard Keynes
was famously very like interested in Freud to some
degree, and I think considered kind of capital as
potentially virulent and so on and so forth. The
thing that I'm doing in this book is trying,
and of course, I'll just say one thing too,
which is that story as well, of economists drawing
from psychological kind of doctrines extends even to this
day in fields like behavioral economics. The story that
I wanted to tell is the inverse story, which
is the use that psychiatrists made of certain forms
of tacit economic thinking to make sense of mental
illness. So that in a weird way, Um, as
I argue, psychiatry has always been using economic styles
of reasoning to make sense of mental illness since
the early 19th century, which is really the formation
of the field of psychiatry.
So, I, I mean, just to clarify, from the
19th century onwards, uh, has there been some, some
form of link between what we consider to be,
uh, madness or any form of mental. ILLNESS more
generally and the ability of people, uh, the ability
that people have to generate economic value.
Not formally, um, and I will say that where
a lot of thinking, there has been a great
deal of thinking about what you might call the
category of irrational behaviors, and you see it from
the writings of Max Weber and on, you see
it in Gary Becker. Irrationalism for them though, always
meant a certain kind of heuristic thinking, dogmatic thinking,
thinking based on traditions and values, and so on
and so forth. And so, I make a distinction
in the book between what you have to understand
as two genres of irrationality. There's irrationalism, which is
like non-instrumental, non-utilitarian thinking, right? Using dogma, or how,
how many of us often think. We, our, our,
our brains tend to work very heuristically, very rhetorically.
And then something like mental illness, which is a
form of irrationalism that is so irrational, it, it
almost never gets talked about. So, in a sense,
there has been, to answer your question, no real
work that has sought to actually link mental illness
and sort of like capitalist or kind of economic.
Enterprise as a kind of project. It's always been
the thing that's been removed. It's like what Foucault
says about Descartes' discussion of madness in the, in
the meditations. He says Descartes simply removes madness from
the scene of discussion. It's not even Worth discussing,
right? It's worth discussing irrational behaviors like heuristic heuristic
thinking, or tradition like traditional thinking, or dogmatic thinking.
But it's, it's never been worth worrying or wondering
whether or not a person with a delusional disorder
can be a good economic actor. That was never
particularly, um, important. There are signs of it, and
I talk about it in the book. So the
writings, for instance, of early Schumpeter, Joseph Schumpeter, and
his discussions of the entrepreneur that he kind of
like develops in the early 20th century. Um, HERE
you have this idea of geniuses, and I talk
about this in detail in the book about the
proximity between the genius and the madman. But it's
still always shrouded in the language of a genius,
of someone who thinks things that are not thought,
you know, in a way, the mentally ill person
and the madman share this idea that they, they
imagine what does not exist. And, and, and I
described that really, the real boundary between the madman
and the, and the, the genius is describing what
doesn't exist. Um, And trying to put it into
fruition creates a division between the genius and the
madman, the economic genius, based simply on the fact
as to whether or not um the thinking results
in some kind of profit or remuneration. So, I
am a madman until my ideas make money, and
then it turns out I'm a genius. But if
they don't, uh
but but please correct me if I'm wrong, but
it seems to me that at least some of
the behaviors that tend to go associated with, uh,
certain, uh, diagnosis of mental illness, uh, involve the.
Inability of a person to adapt to a capitalist
way of living, like for example, their inability to
Um, I, I mean, in, in a way, earn
enough money to sustain themselves, their inability to, uh,
properly manage their financial resources and so on. I,
I, I mean, is that true,
or it, it has been true, and it even
is still true. I've had discussions around this book
with uh practicing psychiatrists and And they will note
actually that even today, one of the standard ways
that a psychiatrist, um, ascertains whether a person has
returned to a state of psychiatric health is largely
they can hold a job. Um, AND there is
this long standing debate as well about commercial society
being what we call pathogenic, um, actually creating mental
illnesses, being like, right, it, it, it can, it
sort of induces states of madness and There, there
is this kind of like, um, double-edged sword, um,
about that I do describe in, in the book
about the, um, writings that talk about how virulent
commercial society is, how much it can cause people
to suffer from all sorts of mental illnesses. And
there were mental illnesses, in, for instance, in the
US, the category of neurasthenia was largely organized around,
uh, like burnout from commercial society. And then at
the very same time that this is happening, where
you then think that somehow capitalism is producing mental
illness, there's an entirely parallel discourse about how sometimes
being a little bit mentally ill, or a little
bit mad, is actually generative of great wealth. Or
being a little bit mad doesn't affect wealth accumulation
at all. So, this, the story of it just
being like, it burns people out, or it, like,
destroys. People or it's traumatic, is merely one side
of a multifaceted story. And I think it's important
to see the multifacetedness of it. And to see,
for instance, and this is again something I discussed
in the book, why some populations are considered more
prone to being burned out by the virulent nature
of capitalism, and why other populations are not. They're
more, let's say, inoculated towards it. And that's a
boundary that in the book I describe. As a
very gendered boundary and a very racialized boundary.
Yeah, but there's certainly an element of psychiatry through
the course of its history, its development, always and
even to this day being influenced by the norms
that are prevalent in a particular society and in
this particular case, since it has developed primarily in
Western capitalist industrialized societies, assuming that people People, I
mean that if someone cannot adapt themselves to living
in such a society with and operating within the
parameters of a capitalist society, holding a job, making
money, sustaining themselves, and so on, that they probably
suffer from some sort of mental disorder, right, because
I mean, I mean, many psychiatrists don't really like
to be confronted with this, but I mean, it's
very much, uh, I think, a fair critique that
many people have about the way that psychiatry operates
within, as I said at the beginning, socio-cultural and
economic context, and, and develops within that context. And
I mean, we could probably say the same for
science more broadly, but anyway, let's not. Get into
that discussion here, but I mean, it could, for
example, be the case that what we consider to
be a maladapted individual in a capitalist society, if
they were just, if they just lived or were
born, born or raised in a different kind of
society, they would just be considered normal.
That's right. You're absolutely right, and I think it's
important to see. How true that is, that psychiatry
cannot help but internalize certain kinds of norms around
capital society. And I'll, I'll say a couple of
points about this as well, just to, um, kind
of elaborate on, on your excellent point, which is
that, um, what you have to understand it, you
know, psychiatry wants Or has wanted to make claims,
um, that it presupposes a very neutral about the
boundary. But of course, the idea of, um, you
know, psychiatry is essentially assessing behavior. I mean, above
all, right? I mean, psychiatry is understood to be
the medicine of the mind. But really, it's about
behavior. Like, we could, uh, just, you know, uh,
we could do a brain scan of my, of
my brain, and it turns out, let's say I
have the brain of someone who should have some
kind of a hallucinatory disorder or someone who is
schizophrenic or whatever. But if none of my behaviors
correspond to this, there's really nothing that can be
done. And I wouldn't. BE diagnosed, right? So, so,
in a sense, psychiatry is always thinking about the
norms of conduct. And of course, the norms of
conduct are so fundamentally shot through with deeper structures
of meaning. And in Western industrial society, those, those
forms of kind of social meaning are, are largely
economic in nature. We, we, Trust people who work.
We, we, right, there's a certain way in which
like a certain capacity with money is seen as
the, the kind of the metric for rational conduct.
Um, ON your point, interestingly, about someone who, let's
say is considered maladaptive because they don't they, they
simply don't want to accept, let's say the terms
of kind of capitalist, liberal capitalist kind of society.
Um, IN many, in many major textbooks written in
European psychiatric writings, immediately following, um, the Paris Commune.
So, in the years just after 1871 and 1972,
you actually get very explicit discussions around the inherent
pathology of political radicalism. So, you get things like
communism or anarchism is seen as in in principle,
a form of psychosis. And it's a form of
psychosis, largely because it refuses to accept a dominant
sociopolitical norm. And in fact, there's one line, and
I could be misremembering it, but it's by Richard
von Kraft Emming in his, in one of the
editions, the earlier editions of his textbook on psychiatry.
SAYS, well, obviously, you know, a communist is insane
because they are delusionally imagining a utopia, which doesn't
exist. And so that must be a form of,
of profound madness. And so that just gets to
your point quite precisely where you begin to have
the pathologization, not just of people who are not
accepting certain kinds of sociopolitical and economic demands, but
also those who fundamentally refuse them. And this extends,
for instance, in into the 20th century around kind
of anti-colonial, anti-imperial. Revolts. People are seen as not
engaged in legitimate anti-imperial uh resistance, but actually are
seen as as being insane. Frantz Fanon talks about
this actually in Wretched of the Earth where he
says there was a view by the French colonizers
that the entire Algerian War was just an expression
of nativist madness rather than a legitimate war for
independence. And so this is just extending the great
point you make, yeah.
Yeah, no, and it's very interesting because you mentioned
earlier, uh Chmpeter and uh I mean the way
that people like him and others, um, basically observed
that perhaps there is some kind of madness associated
with being uh an entrepreneurial genius, but of course
he presents. IT as, uh, for, uh, as being
a genius and not really a madman, but uh
it's actually interesting because, I mean, when you look
at uh many people out there, I mean, for
example, certain billionaires because they expose themselves nowadays a
lot, nowadays a lot in the public space. I
mean, it, it, I, I, I, I guess that
there are two things that we can say here.
So, the first one is that if you, you,
if you were to use the current diagnostic criteria
for, for example, antisocial. Personality disorder, I mean, many
of them would actually be diagnosed as such as
having an antisocial personality disorder. I mean, as being
sociopaths or psychopaths because actually their behavior. Exhibits that
or manifests that. I mean, I mean they are,
they are very vicious. They don't care about much
about empathy for other people. They don't care about
hurting other people, damaging other people in one way
or the other. So, so I mean, I guess
that. On the one hand, you have that and
the fact that perhaps the reason they are not
diagnosed or considered someone that should, for example, be
thrown into a psychiatric ward is that they are
considered functional in the societies. Live in and they
perhaps don't feel enough distress to act to actually,
uh, to actually have, uh, I, I don't know,
psychotherapy sessions or sessions with a psychiatrist and so
on. So that, that's one thing. The other thing
is. That, that perhaps that talks to my earlier
point when I said that the way we consider
someone to be or to suffer from mental disease
actually has a lot to do with them being
considered adapted or. Adapted to the kind of environment
they live in, right, because those particular people, because
they produce or contribute to producing economic value and
are considered productive members of their society within a
capitalist system. They are just usually, at least by
most people, not considered mentally ill.
Yes, and I, I, and just to add to,
it's not just that, um, oddities or eccentricities or
even just flat out transgressive behaviors are tolerated. Or
even revered by some, by many, um, not, not
by me, not by you, but by many. Um,
IT'S not just because these individuals are, are functional
or productive, but that they are highly profitable. They're
incredibly remunerative. So when you look at these billionaires
up close, it's very funny, especially this sort of
tech feudal. You know, tech sovereignty oriented kind of
billionaires, um, when you look at them very closely,
it's kind of hard to see what it is
that they've done exactly that makes them the, the
kind of geniuses they think they are, outside of
just sort of luck and, and entitlement and so
on and so forth. But because around their kind
of cult of personality, wealth is accumulated. It's like
they don't produce anything, but they do generate money.
That their oddities become celebrated and it becomes this
kind of norm, right, that somehow there is some
value in their kind of like, you know, audit.
I'll just give you an example, we can go
the billionaire route, but also, um, Uh, just something
that's been very recent, um, and to sort of
discussed very recently around, um, our, our president Trump,
whose behaviors in terms of particular kind of like
foreign policy have been seen as very erratic. But
what's very interesting is that the erraticness, um, in
the background. Like sometimes the tweets and stuff that
seem very much like they're going from one position
to the other translate into market growth. And it's,
it seems there's a question that People in his
circle are benefiting from this market growth. So, even
what's the sort of erraticness is actually not very
erratic. It's about shifting financial markets and, um, you
know, if I say something, I'm not going to
affect the market. Like I can't just make a
declaration, the oil market's not going to change based
on what I say. But if I were a
president, I could quite do that and I could
potentially take advantage of it. So again, there is
this idea that the erraticness is folded into some
kind of remuneration and it's
yeah, because actually many of those people are also,
and this again would be another diagnostic criterion for
people who have or who are considered as having
antisocial personality disorder, many times they exhibit lots of
impulsive behavior. It's just that their impulsive behavior is
rewarded in some way and and is considered valuable
by society at large. Yeah,
that's exactly right. And, and that's, and I just
want to reiterate, that's the kind of furthest extreme
of a deeper story that I want to say
about mental illness in general being fundamentally coded as
an economic form from the outset. So, whether it's
billionaires or presidents, erratic, impulsive behaviors, or whether it's
you and I. And, and medical assessments that are
made about us, um, largely come down to a
series of economic factors, um. And I think that
that's just a very interesting thing to consider.
Yeah, so I would like to ask you specifically,
I, I think this is a very interesting part
of your book. At a certain point you talk
about the relationship between industrial labor, traumatic occupational psychopathologies,
and the politics of accident insurance legislation. So could
you tell us about that?
Sure, sure. Well, this is one of the chapters
in the book, I think it's called The Pathology
of Work. And it's a chapter that focuses on
a relatively, I think, well, uh, sort of trodden
topic. There, there are, there are topics in this
book that have not received quite a lot of
scholarly attention. I have a whole chapter on, uh,
aphasia, the, uh, the kind of, um, the pathology
of speech law. AND language disorders and testation, the
writing of wills. And that, that's, uh, in my
opinion, a very interesting subject matter that hasn't been
talked about a lot. But this, this chapter, the
pathology of work, we talk about the psychopathology of
occupational disorders. So, uh, traumatic accidents, um, and, and
there has been a fair amount of work, but
I kind of retell this story through a case
study. And this case study is a short-lived, um,
French illness called synerosis that gets coined in the
early 20th century. Um, AND has a very kind
of short shelf life. It kind of comes and,
and goes. But one of the very interesting ideas
about this is that it reframes, um, it, it
sort of tells the story once again of how
psychiatric categories are encoded as, as economic forms. But
this one tells the story of why some kinds
of categories are always seen as a form of
economic loss. And this is the story of a
disorder where a worker, um, an industrial worker, a
kind of laborer in that sense, um, has some
kind of, um, accident on the job and, um,
cannot, as it were, Believe or imagine that they
are cured or recovered in any way, and so
they have persistent need to continue to ask for
some kind of remuneration either through litigious means or
through eventually what become in the context of Europe.
Uh, NATIONALIZED legislation for occupational, uh, accidents. And it's
seen as a kind of veritable psychosis, like this
laborer just feels entitled to be kind of paid.
And there are these interesting conversations that are happening,
uh, throughout the European kind of context, especially in
Germany and also in France, that the real culprit
behind this psychosis, the reason for why laborers feel
as if they are actually being injured. So the
idea is laborers feel very fragile, they feel like
they're victimized, they feel like they're being injured all
the time. The real culprit isn't the laborer themselves.
And of course, the psychiatrists believe they're being very
good people by not blaming the workers. The, the
culprit here is actually the legislation itself, that somehow
worker oriented legislation that protects workers' well-being, that's, that,
that, that remunerate that, that, you know, pays them
if they're injured. That this is actually inducing in
them a kind of delusion that they're all in
a state of injury. And so it's a, it's
a kind of tacit critique of liberal legislation that's
worker oriented. Um, THERE'S a lot going on in
this chapter, and one of the things that I
try and do is offer a kind of genealogy
of this, um. Of this category and a and
a genealogy, this discourse that runs through a number
of discourses, including the long history of the forensic
psychiatry, the medical legal discussions, specifically around the idea
of simulating. So this is one of the criticisms
that's often made is that someone is actually faking
an illness and, and psychiatric illnesses have been seen
as one of the, the, the illnesses that people
have been supposedly faking for the entire kind of
modern era. And so it deals with this, it
deals with a number of different, like the political
economy of occupational psychosis as well, or occupational um
injuries, um. There's a lot to say here. I,
I don't want to, there's, there's, I don't want
to unpack it because we'll be here kind of
all day just talking about this, this section. But,
um, this is seen really as the inverse story
of what we just talked about. So the way
an erratic kind of billionaire can, can act terribly
and in fact, quite pathologically, but be rewarded in
a sense culturally. And socially because they generate wealth.
Here, a laborer, their illness is seen as fundamentally
costly, because it's costing an industry or it's costing
a state money. And so, they're, the, the kind
of the financial encodement of their mental illness is
seen as pure loss. And so, this is sort
of the flip side.
Right. I, I mean that, that also reminds me
of when, for example, people, uh, and this perhaps
has also something to say about how we view
or how we tend to make assumptions about people
from different socioeconomic strata because for example, if someone
who is on the poorer end of the spectrum,
uh, if they, for example, have a quote unquote
gamble. ADDICTION and they waste all their money and
they get evicted from their home and they go
to live on the street, they become homeless, then
we see that as a form of psychopathology. But
if a billionaire or a multi-millionaire bets their money
on, on the, uh, bet, bets, bets their money
on the on the exchange market or something like
that. That, I mean, basically they're also, uh, they
also have that kind of uh gambling mentality, but
it's not considered psychopathological. I mean, sometimes they might
lose a lot of money and they might get
help from banks or the state or something like
that. Other times they just might get. Yeah, they
just might get, yeah, sorry, go ahead.
Yeah, just to say too, I mean, the very,
as you say, that the whole, the bailing out,
so private equity is just gambling. I mean, it's
just a gambling that's, but the fact that, um,
like you and I, if we gamble and we
lose our money, we're not going to get bailed
out that the that the reason for that. This
is that in precisely because we're not seen as
fundamentally, like, profitable in that sense, right? So, there's
some, that, that, that valuation is already oriented in
terms of that boundary structure between a very wealthy
corporation or entity or person and someone who is,
who does not kind of have that kind of
accumulated wealth. That's already a kind of Value appraisal
that's being made. We don't deserve to get bailed
out because that was our mistake. It was our
responsibility, and it's our kind of pathology, and we
need to be responsible for ourselves. But here, uh,
of course, a company is betting on this, that,
the other thing. But because the potential wealth that
can come out of it is so immense, it's
seen as fun. Valuable. That's a very simple kind
of point. But it's an, I think it, it,
it's a deeper point, or rather, it points or
index is a very deeper way in which we
appraise this boundary of norm and abnormality around kind
of class structure.
Yeah, sure, and I mean, I think also that
we sometimes are sort of blind to the fact
that if they bet millions or even billions of
dollars on the stock market and they make a
bad bet and they lose it all and then
they they get sort of bailed out. By private
banks or by the state itself. Uh, I mean,
that just happens because people look at those people
differently and think that they're still, they're still able
to produce high amounts of money even though because
of that they might even sometimes crash entire economies
and ruin the lives of millions. And billions of
people, and on the other hand, we have people
that perhaps they bet a few $1000 and they
lose it all and suddenly we look at them
as losers even though they're just hurting themselves or
maybe their family, but it's just a handful of
people and
that's, and that's the difference is if you and
I do that and we lose all of our
money betting. We all, that, that there's a kind
of reflexive way that we are pathologized. But when
a major corporation, the very fact that there is
not, I mean, you and I might say these
are pathological individuals, but from a general kind of
cultural, socio-cultural consensus, that's the, the very lens of
pathology or the very frame of pathology is not
attributed to them because of the amount of wealth
that's there. So, the premise This is, well, they
can't be crazy because at some point, they made
a lot of money. So, obviously, it's just a
bad call. Whereas you and I might have one
bad call, but because the amount of wealth or
that history of wealth accumulation isn't there, we become
much more readily pathologized. And again, this is, this
is the kind of story, there's a kind of
underlying kind of logic to all of this, which
is what I have been trying in this book
to kind of like bring to the, kind of
bring out into the light. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, uh, I mean, there's also
this, uh, there's also this very interesting topic that
you explore in your book and actually, I've been
trying to talk with, uh, psychiatrists or people who,
um, I mean, explore psychiatry as a research topic,
whether they are sociologists or some other people like
as a as a philosopher sometimes. Uh, I mean,
at a certain point in the book, um, you
talk about how For example, an individual might adopt
and internalize an economic style of psychiatric reasoning, and
then such a style of functions as a hermeneutic
strategy for self-intelligibility. So, uh, could you explain that
and then I, I might ask you about the
an idea I have about that.
Of course, yeah. Without going into too much detail,
one of the chapters in the book is something.
Akin to a kind of a biography of an
American Gilded Age millionaire. They weren't billionaires as of
yet, I think in the 1890s. Uh, HE was
a, um, an Astor, that is to say, one
of the relatives, the great, great grandson of John
Astor. So, um, a great inheritor of kind of
New York wealth. And his name was John Chandler.
He, he changed his name to John Armstrong Challoner.
Um, HE'S a kind of little well known figure.
Um, uh, HE suffered, allegedly from what I think
was a legitimate psychiatric disorder. I mean, he heard
voices, essentially. And, um, but he never perceived his
oddity, his abnormality as a kind of a medical
ailment. He perceived it as something like a psychological
power. And an economic asset. And he used it.
What's interesting is that he um made sense of
his madness as if it were from the start,
a kind of an economic form. And it's very
interesting because, um, He, uh, uh, often would engage
in tests to confirm whether or not this was
sort of true. So he would play the stock
market because the voice told him. He also named
his voice, he called it the X faculty. It
told him to bet on this or do this
or do something here. Um, HE, uh, um. Invested
in, um, Southern textiles. It was not uncommon for
wealthy New Yorkers to invest in Southern cotton. In
fact, the cotton industry is excellent work. I don't,
this is not work I produce, but draw on
a great deal of, of the cotton industry in
the South, both antebellum and postbellum is, was coming
from new finance. So he, he, he actually starts,
uh, a textile town, or at least is one
of the founders of it that actually becomes quite
profitable. He's not able to make use of the
profit because his family has him committed. Um, THE,
the point of this story, it's a, it's a
kind of tragic narrative in, in some ways, and,
and I'm not interested in, in extolling him whatsoever.
I actually think he was a deeply person with
incredibly heinous kind of politics. Uh, ONE of the,
the points that I want to make in this
book is one of the reasons that he felt
entitled to think about his abnormality, not as a
pathology, but as an economic asset, had a lot
to do with the fact that he was very
well aware that he was a wealthy white man.
And so there is this thing that I call
In the book of pathological entitlement, that he, he
felt like he had the kind of social, political
and economic status by which to understand what would
otherwise be understood as, let's say, a kind of
psychological disorder is actually this great kind of laudatory
asset. And I think this is something we see
a kind of style of thinking that we see
even to this day, uh, with the billionaires and
the so on and so forth, where people clearly
have what you earlier described as some kind of
a like maladaptive kind of, you know, they're, they're,
they have impulse control problems, this, that and the
other thing. But they don't see themselves as um
problematic, the way you and I might, if that,
because it would actually jeopardize jeopard jeopardize our lives
and our careers in a certain way, but they
see it as actually this, this asset that they
can profit off of in a certain, in a
certain sense. And so, um, Uh, one of the
things that I wanted to do in, in this
chapter was to say that this idea of madness
being economically encoded is not simply happening way up
here in the literature, in the discourse, in the
psychiatric theory. But it is actually disseminating into what
you might call or what I just to draw
on someone like Foucault, a technology of the self,
a way that um a a kind of discursive
set of uh a reservoir of discourses by which
people can start to interpret themselves. And so, I
think, um, We, we tend to think of like
our uniqueness or our, our oddities or this, that
other thing as potentially part of a, a portfolio
of ourselves that we can kind of draw on
to generate wealth or to generate success in our
lives or in our careers. We think of this
as a very neoliberal phenomenon. So, a, a style
of self that really doesn't emerge until the 1970s,
the 1980s. But I want to suggest that actually
something like this is, is emergent, even in the
late 19th century, where someone could imagine what would
otherwise, in many other social contexts, be seen as
a liability to actually imagine it as a profound
asset.
OK, so you, you mentioned the word interpreting or
interpretation there and that exactly connects to the kind
of idea I have and I would like to
run it through you to see what you think
about it. So, I mean, when it comes to,
for example, uh someone getting a uh medic uh
psychiatric diagnosis or a clinical psychology diagnosis, so let's
say that someone is diagnosed as Uh, depressed, they're
suffering from a major depression or something like that.
I mean, uh, uh, these are just ideas that,
that I have. Uh, I mean, sometimes I talk
with psychiatrists and clinical psychologists about it, and, uh,
sometimes I have sort of positive reactions or sometimes
not so positive reactions because they might think that
I'm just, um, telling them that they, what they
do is, BS. It's not exactly that that I'm
doing, but I mean, so isn't there, and particularly
this aspect of self-intelligibility and interpreting oneself in a
particular way, I mean, it always makes me think
about two things. So the first one is, isn't
there the possibility that that if someone starts integrating
into their identity, the idea that they They are
a depressive person that perhaps they might adopt the
scheme that comes with being a depressive person and
they sort of become more entrenched into the behaviors
and patterns of what that were associated with being
depressed. So that's one thing. And the other thing
is I'm Isn't there a possibility that perhaps sometimes,
I'm not sure about all the time, but sometimes
these labels might help people, but in the sense
that they provide them with new narratives to interpret
or reinterpret their lives in a way that makes
them make sense for them, makes their lives make
sense. Sense for them, but what we're talking about
there is not really having an objective look at
their lives, but having sort of a reinterpretation of
what their lives were up to that point and
what they could do with it. I mean, does
this make sense or makes perfect
sense. It's an excellent question. I'll say two things
provisionally. First, um, I, I am not a psychiatrist
or a clinician. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, which is
good, because I think, interestingly, you're not asking a
clinical question. You're actually asking a question that is
a question at the intersections of theories of subjectivity
and social theory. You're asking essentially social formation, excuse
me, subject. Formation. How, how does a self, a
sense of self cohere in a particular kind of
social context? And how does it cohere, given the
background discourse of something like psychiatry, kind of operating
in the back? I'll say a couple of things
just in, in response, because I agree with the
premises of, of your, of your question. I agree
with it fundamentally. I think that, um, and, you
know, uh, people will disagree, but I think the
disagreements are going to be largely disciplinary disagreements. I
think, I think subjectivity is, is an, is an
artifact that is to say, I'm not saying it's
fake. I'm saying it's an, it's an artifact. That
is to say, it's, it's contingent, historically contextual and
specific. So, the ways in which my sense of
self coheres now in the 21st century is going
to be very different than how it might have
cohered 1000 years ago. Um, THE, the, the, the,
the discourses, the truths, the world in which I
am drawing from is fundamentally kind of different. And
so, the world in which we draw our sense
of interiority, our sense of self, is, is a
world comprised in our contemporary moment, largely from the
human sciences. So the human sciences offer Um, some
of the most forceful schemas by which we make
sense of ourselves. But at the same time, the
human sciences are not based on a pillar of
light from God revealing the truth of things. The
human sciences are are historically constructed institutions that are
politically, uh, grounded, economically grounded, socially grounded, culturally, so
on and so forth. And so, in that sense,
um, I think, in fact, um, one of the
ways to think about psychiatry, which I think is
very, very interesting, is the extent to which, um,
between the year 1826, which is kind of one
of the moments in which psychiatry is really beginning
to professionalize, like, in, in the most forceful ways,
it's going to be another couple decades before we
really start to see. Um, STATE-BASED asylums and so
on and so forth, but just to use 1826
to 2026, 1 of the differences that we see
is that in 2026, people have an increasing tendency
to use psychiatric language to understand their sense of
self in a way that they didn't quite in
1826. And I think that has largely
yeah, yeah, there, there's, there's even that. I think
that phenomenon that you see occurring on social media
where people complain, for example, about other people. INSTRUMENTALISING
the use of, uh, therapy speak to manipulate others,
for example. Oh, I, I, I suffer from this,
and then they start using the uh the um,
the terms that uh psychotherapists or psychiatrists usually use
in a um a therapeutic context. TO sort of,
um, I mean, have an upper end against the
people that they are, they are trying to present
themselves as better than or
something like that or even more benign, the fact
that there is a tendency to invoke certain kinds
of identity markers and The, uh, you know, one
of the most common ones, of course, is, is
gender identity. And another increasingly common one is psychiatric
identity. I mean, this just is, it, I mean,
this is a not a not uncommon way people
kind of present themselves. There's a similar story that
can be told around gender identity and why something
like gender becomes a way in which people come
to identify the truth of themselves. And I think
psychiatry is following suit, though it, it is maybe
a little bit later in that kind of historical
development, because in 1826, there was less of an
incitement, I think, for people to really identify with
a psychiatric diagnosis than there is today. And, and
I think that in that identification, As you rightly
put, you introduce all the schemas that come with
it. So, in a sense, you not only identify
with it, but then you, in some respects, allow
that identification to fill in the gaps that render
more and more coherent your subjectivity. So, for instance,
you know, for instance, let's say I decide, and
it's just a very thought experiment, I decide, I,
you know, I, I, I read about the London
Marathon and some, you know, 2 runners beat the
2 hour mark, and now I decide I want
to be a runner and I'm going to go
marathon. And I slowly start to build a kind
of identity as a runner, right? And so I
allow, so I, I start to identify and then
I allow it to shape future identity. So I
start to do things as a runner might and
so on and so forth. And you can make
a similar kind of an analogy. I mean, it's
a, it's a, it's a very facile analogy, but
it's, it's, I think, a functional one with a
psychiatric diagnosis as well.
It's, it's like, or along the lines of when
people Say, oh, I was born to be a
doctor or something like that. Yeah, yeah, because I,
because I mean, people fail to realize that that's
very circumstantial. I mean, if they were born in
a society without doctors, of course, they wouldn't say
that because that possibility wouldn't even be there.
Exactly. And not even just a career, but I
even think an even stronger kind of. Um, EXAMPLE
would be something like an astrological sign. I was
born as a Taurus, or I'm a a Virgo.
And so, this is how I am. And so
you read about what Virgos do and maybe it
influences you. And by the way, there's, you know,
the, the excellent kind of scholarly point about this
is the late philosopher of science, Ian Hacking, and
his looping effects. So, the idea that a person
internalizes a certain kind of a psychiatric disorder, in
some respects, um, um, Shapes themselves in relation to
the disorder, but not entirely. And so, in some
respects, there's, uh, instances of incompatibility with what they
might imagine a depressive personality to be. And then
that, that inconsistent inconsistency goes back into the diagnostic
category. So that, so that so-called depressants are acting
like this, but not like that, and then the
category shifts. And it kind of loops over and
over again. And there, there are benefits and drawbacks
to that, which we don't need to describe, that's
going into kind of like minutia territory. I will
say one point though, about all of this, which
is that when you look at the history of
psychiatry, and I'm talking now about why is it
that in 1826, psychiatric identification was not as strong
as it was in 2026. There are a couple
explanations for this. Well, first, the most obvious one
is, it's, it's two centuries of an entrenchment of
psychiatry. And then psychiatric discourse is everywhere, right? I
mean, it's in schools, and hospitals, it's in courtrooms,
it's in popular cultures, it's in TV shows. There's
really no way to escape it. It's very, very
diffuse and very ever present. So, of course, it's
not surprising that it would affect people in this
way. But there's something else to consider too, which
is that there's, there's an entire political economy that
underwrites this, um, this incitement to identify. And this
is not something I talk about explicitly in the
book, but it certainly comes out of it. If
you look at the history of psychiatry, one of
the most interesting characteristics of it is that psychiatric
classifications. Typically are remarkably transient. They come and they
go. They come and they go. Monomania comes and
goes, hysteria comes and goes, and so on and
so forth. The very interesting thing to consider about
a psychiatric classification, given that it is normally prone
to transience, is to consider when it becomes entrenched,
when a psychiatric category stays, and why it stays.
Why does it stabilize? And what's very interesting is
one of the explanations for why a psychiatric category
stabilizes has quite a lot to do with the
political economy of psychopharmaceuticals. The longer a psychiatric disorder
stays existing, the longer my medication will become profitable,
in some respects, right? And so, and the longer
it stays, and the longer it becomes profitable, and
the more it diffuses itself culturally, the more people
might be inclined to begin to identify with it
for a variety of reasons. And then that leads
us to another kind of question, which I don't
talk about in the book at all, because it's
too early historically to talk about it, which is
about biocapital or the industry of psychopharmaceuticals, which I
will just say one point about this is, it's,
it's not just the case that psychopharmaceuticals are one
of the most highly prescribed medications in the United
States, especially antidepressants. So they are a remarkably profitable
kind of drug base, but What's very interesting over
the past 10 years, is that, um, a lot
of pharmaceutical companies have actually stopped producing more pharmaceuticals.
And the reason for this is that, although psychopharmaceuticals
are very profitable, they don't have quite the market
growth of other kinds of medications. So, in an
interesting thing, what I imagine happening moving forward is
we're going to have fewer and fewer new pharmaceuticals
on the market. And new sort of new pharmaceuticals
dealing with new disorders on the market. And so,
I think this is going to be a very
interesting thing to consider, what's going to happen in
the next 30 or 40 years, in terms of
psychiatric classifications, when one of the engines, um, kind
of Moving the, the, the, the, like, moving the
clock or whatever on the, the state of classifications,
those that engine being the industry of psychopharmaceutical is
going to diminish. And I'm curious to see what's
to the classification disorders moving forward.
Yeah, so I mean one thing that I was
going to say, or actually let me ask you
this because we've already talked about what is considered
to be irrational and how psychiatry deals with irrationality,
but I mean, how about morality. Does morality also
weigh in on how psychiatrists classify mental disorders? I
mean, are what we consider in a particular society
to be immoral people or immoral behaviors also considered
pathological.
This is a great question. And, and it's a
theme that I talk about in the book as
well. There's sort of three ways that I think
about the category of value, which is through the
lens of medicine, the lens of economics, and the
lens of morality. Each of these has a kind
of value marker to it. Health is considered valuable.
Um, Obviously, uh, wealth is, is, is a form
of value. And we talk about moral value in
a certain way. And, and I actually try very
intentionally to collapse these terms, or the collapse these
sort of like lenses. And the reason I do
this is because there is a point that I
think is very important that, um, Michelle Foucault made
in the History of Madness, the very first kind
of book, which is that in the early modern
period, Um, you get this change that happens with
respect to madness. And it's a change that seems
to have sort of, um, it continues in some
respects to be the case even today, which is
that madness was, in the early modern period, moralized
in a very specific way. And it was moralized
as a form of, like, um, Uh A certain
kind of immoral conduct. And I know that's a
very strange thing to say that madness is being
moralized. And I want to be very clear, while
in the, in the long history of, of madness
being medicalized, There is still a certain way in
which the mentally ill. Continue to carry this baggage
that Foucault describes. It's the baggage of idleness. In
a sense, the mentally ill person was from the,
from the, essentially from the 18th century on, seen
as the individual who cannot partake in market activities.
This is the person who cannot work. This is
the person who cannot, as it were, contribute. It's
a certain form of moralization that's attributed to the
mental illness. So, the idea is not that the,
the The cause of mental illness is immorality. You
know, the cause is medical. The cause is, as
it were, biological, in, in the writings. But the
effect is that the mentally ill are sidelined, sidelined
from moral productivity. And so, madness then, has long
been not only a medical category, but a moral
category. And I think there's still a way in
which the shame. There's still shame organized around mental
illness, this sort of sense that you're not able
to contribute, that you're, that you're going to be
disruptive in a certain way, that you're, you, you're,
you're kind of disrupting social order in a certain
sense. You're kind of introducing disharmony. One of the
things I suggest though, is that if in fact.
Um, There is a way that madness is an
economic form allows for the reappraisal of what you
might say otherwise pathological people who make money. Suddenly,
you have this inversion around the moral status, so
that it's good sometimes to be a little bit
mentally ill. So that you have this very strange
shift that happens in the moral appraisal of madness
itself, if that makes sense. So, um, so, the,
the, the more The moral category runs throughout the
book. And it's a very important kind of element
that I think is really key for us to
consider tacitly often, if I have a kind of
mental illness or a mental disability or a disability
of any sort, I have a certain kind of,
I mean, I'm, I'm speaking for myself, a sort
of disinclination to want to make it public. Because
of how I imagine I'll be viewed, right? And
I think that there's a, there's a difference, though,
if in fact, let's say I have this thing
that one of my historical actors calls an X
faculty, and it's making me money hand over fist,
I will want to actually talk about it in
a great, great detail. And it kind of reestablishes
the, the, the kind of moral hierarchy that we
have long attributed to something like madness.
Yeah, I mean, it reminds me of the fact
that, for example, uh, more, particularly more ancient thinkers,
but also, I mean, you, I think you can
still see that in at least, I mean, I
don't, perhaps not so much in the kinds of
ideas they expressed, but at least in, in the
way they lived in some more modern thinkers, particularly
philosophers and others. I mean, where, I mean, just
to give an example, in, in ancient. Greece, I
mean, the, the most prominent philosophers that we know,
I mean, it wouldn't be odd at all for
them to praise leisure time and to say that
even, I mean, having to work for money was
beneath themselves and I mean it it would, it
would be more virtuous even to just dedicate yourself
to philosophy, to Uh, higher ways of, uh, conducting
yourself and, uh, and, uh, and thinking and producing
knowledge and so on. Uh, uh, AND, and now,
uh, for in more recent times, in more modern
times with the, with the advent of capitalism and
for example, uh, the Development of Protestant Christianity and
particularly more so Calvinism. There's this obsession with working
and producing and contributing to the economy, producing economic
value, and so on. Which is something that is
not at all a human universal and even in
our sort of Western, even Judeo-Christian tradition wouldn't be
considered as such or wouldn't be considered as important
for most of our history. I mean, people valued
leisure. Time people valued being able to just have
time for thinking and discussing ideas with other people
without necessarily even tying knowledge to economic value as
we have even nowadays in academia where I mean
you even have to justify a sort of economically
why you're going to. The particular subject to get
grants and all of that. So I mean that
this is again, I guess to say that we
really can't be blind to the sort of, uh,
in this case, particularly economic conditions that we live
in and the economic system we live under,
right? I agree with you completely and, and one
of the points I make strongly, especially towards the
end of the book. IS to suggest um that
I, and I believe this, that our The very
structure of our moral intelligibility today is fundamentally suffused
with economic logics, to the point that I don't
think we know how to kind of think otherwise.
And I draw on quite a lot of kind
of social thought to, to kind of make this
point. But I also suggest that looking at the
history of psychiatry and the way that I narrate
it, helps us see even more why the economic
has so fundamentally suffused the moral. And part of
the reason for this is because in the kind
of like post 18th century period, Um, a lot
of the ways by which we think about moral
right and moral wrong tends to be through the
language of the human sciences. We don't often use
the language of evil to describe people who do
incredibly horrific or pernicious things. We tend to invoke
psychiatric language. We, we suggest that they're sociopaths, they're
psychopathic, there's something wrong with their brains, and so
on and so forth. And so, psychiatry or kind
of like a language of the human sciences has
largely taken over the task of what classical moral
thought had done. Even if we still use moral
claims, I think, unconsciously, we mean it in a
scientific sense. And because the economic Essentially suffused the
psychiatric, that has become the kind of Trojan horse
by which economics has essentially suffused moral thinking. And
I think I say at one point, our modern
moral economy is more economic than it is moral.
And I think that there's something about that, that
is, um, worth kind of, um, Not just considering,
but being like very concerned about, to be honest.
Yeah, so, uh, I have one last question. I
mean, everything that we've been talking about here and
of course, uh, other topics that you explore in
your book, do you think that uh people can
pick on all of this to, uh, use it
as a critique of capitalism, uh, or is, or
was that not your intention to, uh, use it
as a critique of capitalism. BUT just as presented
as a new way of looking at the link
between uh economic thought or the kind of, uh,
in this particular case, capitalist economic system that we
live in and how that relates to the development
of psychiatry and how we understand psychiatric conditions just
from a more neutral point of view.
This is a great question. And, and I will
be very straightforward that from, from my standpoint, this
book was from the outset intended to be a
critique of capitalism. Um, AND, and in that sense,
though, a critique that's told from a maybe slightly
different or a more Unique or whatever kind of
standpoint, where in the sense that we typically in
kind of think about critiques of capital, uh, like
the quite literally like a formal a formal critique
of capital being a largely Marxist or Marxian kind
of project. And it's not one that I am
any way trying to disavow. It's merely trying to
show a kind of different entry point to thinking
about capitalism from a critical standpoint, from a, a
critical and kind of genealogical standpoint, and from a
discourse that we might not otherwise expect. So, not
from the standpoint of political economy, but actually from
psychiatry. And, um, and, but it's also an effort
to show. At least in part, the challenge of
a critique of capital, that as I said earlier
in our discussion, that to simply draw out the
contradictions or the irrationalism of capitalism may not be
sufficient, a sufficient enough critique that in fact, as
I say, There's a kind of way that capitalism
and and irrationality have had a, a morbid dance
for a very long time. And, um, in that
sense, it, and, and, and if an infant, if
in fact, our moral economies are also in, in
large part, um, contaminated by economic thinking. Then what
does it actually mean to position oneself in contradistinction
to, to capitalism? What does it mean to actually
separate ourselves from capital? What does it mean to
actually engage in some kind of like, An emancipatory
act that would require us, and I think this
is one of the, the things I kind of
end with, it's not just an emancipation from institutions,
but an emancipation from kind of forms of subjectivity
that have been shaped by capitalism. And it's a
subject formation that, as I say, has taken over
the entire language of psychiatry, which is such a
great, such a significant part of how we understand
ourselves today. So, They're, they're, I, I'm engaging in
a critique of capital and from a tradition that
might be something more drawn from social theory, um,
that has a more of like a Foolian orientation,
Webarian orientation, but one that I want to suggest
is profoundly compatible with the critiques of capitalism that
we're familiar with. It's just a different, a different
story, a different orientation, but the aim, the aim,
the critical aim is still the same.
Yeah, but if, for example, someone who identifies as
a Marxist, a socialist, a communist, or something like
that, an anarchist even perhaps, would read your book
and say, oh, so look, I read Dr. Basiri's
book Madness and Enterprise, and I will use some
of the arguments. He makes there some of the
information he makes there to uh make a case
against capitalism. I mean, you wouldn't be opposed to
that or
no, I would hope, I would hope for that.
That would be the, that would be the goal.
And to, so that I, you know, a, a
critique of capitalism needs, in my opinion, to be
a multi-pronged approach, and we need to see it,
um, we need to see the sort of its
tentacles in all aspects of our lives, and especially.
In the places we did not expect it to
be. And I think that that's one of the
things. So, as I say, towards the end of
the book, I am not even doing in, to
the extent that this is formally a critique of
psychiatric thinking, right? Because that's the topic. I'm not
suggesting that actually, it's the institution of psychiatry, which
is the problem, like the way that professional, I
think that's a problem too, but There's been work
on it. I want to suggest that the very
concept of mental illness has been transformed into an
economic form. So, the very thinkability of health and
unhealth is fundamentally shaped by capitalist kind of forces
and structures, so that it's not just about institutional
transformation. It's a kind of, you might call a
profound epistemological, even an ontological endeavor that I think
is, is really demanded. So, I really want to
show that um a critique of capital needs to
go. Maybe even further than we imagine it to
go, that it's not just enough to transform the
infrastructure of a polity, that might not be enough.
There needs to be something possibly kind of more.
Mhm. Yeah, I, I mean, and just to make
this point clear because of course I, uh, presented
here some ideas that people could pick on them
and say, oh yeah, then the psychiatry and clinical
psychology are just useless. But I, I mean that,
uh, just to clarify that those were not the
points I was making, I was just saying that
we have to look at those. Disciplines or whatever
you want to call them as as things that
operate within a particular sociocultural and in this case
as we talked about here today, economic context and
that I mean if it helps people, great, I'm
all for it, but it's just that we have
to Be mindful that it operates under particular constraints.
It's not really about, it's not really about objective
reality, to a great extent. It's an interpretation of
social reality and also, I, I mean, I I
guess that uh. There are another point is that
psychiatry and clinical psychology, at least in my understanding,
this is just my opinion. I don't know if
you agree with it or not, but shouldn't be
the alpha and omega of how people deal with
their own psyches because there probably are other. Cultural
tools, cultural technologies out there that can be as
effective or as good for people, for people's psychological
well-being as psychiatry and clinical psychology are. Yeah,
I, you know, as scholars, I think it's very
important for us to be able to and to
willfully. Um, HAVE multiple and sometimes incompatible thoughts at
the same time. We can look at the institution
of modern medicine and say, it is important, it
helps people. People should have access to it. Personally,
I think people should have unencumbered access to it.
That is to say, universally available access to it,
paid for by a public, universally bought to. Um,
AND, and I say this is also the case
with, uh, the medicine of mind, clinical psychiatry. I
think it is profoundly helpful for people. Um, AS
to the kind of alpha omega quality, I think
that, um, I, I, I think like any medicine,
some people respond to some medicines better than other
medicines. And whether that's a, uh, a form of
psychotherapeutic, whether that's a, uh, an antibiotic, that's a,
that's, that's the kind of pluralism that's present in
the fact that medicine is engaged in life and
the, the, and the living organism is an incredibly
multifaceted thing. We can say this and also say
that medicine is a product of historical moments, that
it is suffused with structures and infrastructures and institutional
commitments, that, um, it's not about it being nefarious,
but it is simply a fact. Uh, MODERN medicine
emerges at the same time, for instance, as modern
economic forms, and it would be actually shocking and
strange if they weren't so fundamentally interwoven. It would
be odd. It wouldn't make any sense, actually. And
so we can have, we can have both thoughts
simultaneously. And I think the question then becomes, um,
what is the kind of ethical aim to the
extent that we can have one, if we, you
know, we want to say people should have access
to medicine, I think this should also, you know,
to, to what end? Well, because people should be
able to live healthy and flourishing lives. OK, to
what end? If I'm being kept alive, simply because
I need to be economically productive. So, I'm being
kept alive, so I can just keep making money
for someone else, that's a very strange way of
valuing my life. So, just to suggest that someone
should be alive for the sake of being alive,
is not, in my opinion, a rigorously scholarly conclusion.
We have to keep asking for. Further to live
for what end? Um, AS you say, like what
the ancient philosophers used to say, uh, to live
a life of flourishing, to live a life of
virtue, right? And I think virtue can't happen if
you're working 3 or 4 jobs and, and so
on and so forth. There was one point I
wanted to make interestingly about this idea of the,
the moral, which I forgot to say. And back
to the point, our whole idea of morality is
totally suffused with economics. I, I use often in
my classroom, the language of successful. If I were
to say Ricardo is a very successful person, people
are going to say, oh, what does Ricardo do?
The immediate thought is your success is tied up
to your economic productivity. But if I say, oh,
no, he's he's, he's successful because he engages in
virtue, like Plato, you know, he, he's like, he
has, he has virtue. She has achieved virtue. People
are going to think I'm crazy, or you're crazy,
or I'm making a joke. So the very idea
of what it means to be successful, like you,
we don't even have moral success anymore. Like, that's
not even a thing that we have. It's always
a kind of like career-based success, and economic based
success. And then that just gets to this other
point. And that ties to this idea that we
can hold two thoughts together. There is a profound
significance to psychiatric medicine, as it is for all
medicines, and at the same time, point out that
medicine is not immune from structures of the, the
realities in which they find themselves, um, um, situated
within.
Yeah, OK, great. So the book is again Madness
and Enterprise Psychiatry, Economic Reason and the Emergence of
Pathological Value. I'm of course leaving a link to
it in the description of the interview. And Dr.
Basiri, apart from the book, are there any places
on the internet where people can find you and
your work?
Yes, um, you can. I have a website, nema
Basiri.com, which I try and keep updated. You can
also find me, um, through, uh, Duke University, the
program in literature. It's literature.duke.edu. Um, I also am
the director of the Frederick Jamison Institute for Critical
Theory, and you can find us there online at
criticaltheory.trinity.duke.edu.
Great, I will add that to the description and
thank you so much for taking the time to
come on the show. It's been a really fascinating
conversation and I mean, if you're open to it,
I would love to have you back on the
show someday.
Yes, I would love that. Thank you so much.
It's been a great talk.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights, Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at lights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andre, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and Samuel
Cerri, Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezara Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Rusmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alec Baka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffyani Smith,
and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgius Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank, Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al
Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.